hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm going to beat this game I've
literally got all day long I don't care
how long it takes I've got all damn day
I'm gonna play this until I beat it
because I'm tired of people constantly
going
why don't you buy routers again who do
you be scaredy baby cat and I'm like
have you seen the [ __ ] that this game
puts me through have you seen the bull
honkey I have planned this game for
hours and there's been like hours of
time where I've tried it one more time I
thought hey I'll throw up the webcam and
I'll try to record it and just maybe
it'll not be a giant douche to me no it
is then I scrap like hours of recording
just because I'm like oh I can't
possibly do this again I've got nothing
left to talk about this game I've done
like six episodes and it's the same
thing over and over and yet it still
manages to screw me over so here I am
one last time I'm gonna play this game
until I beat it and I don't care how
long it takes but like I said I don't
really have anything else to talk about
so I'm gonna tell you guys about the
history of America because I got nothing
else to talk about so as Americans if
you don't know already if you do then I
mean sing along with me as you recite
the history the illustrious history of
America we wake up each morning and then
praise the wooden teeth of George
Washington and say our daily prayers to
the Blessed beard of Abraham Lincoln
from his top hat to his lovely beard may
he keep us safe as we go along and thank
our creators for our daily McDonald's
hamburger why it's delicious but anyway
the history America was founded in like
1480 [ __ ] I don't know on the principle
of [ __ ] you
that is American that is the American
Way we have always taught our children
great straight from birth [ __ ] you and
just [ __ ] all y'all and go to hell and
let's see how badly we can screw up the
entire world so anyway we landed on the
shores of New Jersey and the swole
Native Americans came out and they're
like sup nerds nice belts on your half
and we're all we're British at this time
so we're like why did much careful you
mmm I don't think we're going to get
along oh no we're starving and then
they're like the Native Americans like
you need some protein bruh here take
this fish in this corn thing and we're
like what's going and we're like eating
the corn and then we're like oh this is
awesome you guys are amazing hey can we
have all this country in the swole
Native American relate I don't know that
doesn't seem very fair to us and then
they go off their business and we're
like we got to get rid of these guys cuz
we suddenly turning into giant [ __ ]
and then we decide to go try to be
friends with them in the soil of Native
Americans are like hey bruh
god dammit so many dead ends here oh
come on
go so anyway the swole Native Americans
were going about their business and we
were just like hey you need anything
from us I don't know disease starvation
bullets to the head you need anything at
all and they were like oh you know we're
okay we're we're doing just fine living
amongst the land peacefully and not
being total [ __ ] Americans like you
guys are we didn't even know what
America was but you guys are just giant
douches and so we decided oh can we
cooperate you you might need something
from us we need something from you and
they're like maybe we need more sweat
towels for our massive workouts cuz
Native Americans are so amazingly
awesome and they are but we were like oh
yeah yeah sure yeah sure
hey ah smallpox Larry you got a few
spare blankets we Cocozza and then we
kill them all
we kill them all and that's how we
started our tradition - [ __ ] you and
then we win a golf learn how many dead
ends do I need a cricket Willy
yeah you get all ready to pitch and then
then we we're total dick bags Americans
founded their entire nation on killing
people and taking their stuff and then
we are where we're here today throughout
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
and the blessed Ben Franklin make his
classes watch us from high above where
he is certainly watching us from that
great big McDonald's in the sky and
that's history of America as literally
all I've got for this episode unless for
some damn reason you want me to tell
more history of him
what is what am I even doing here I
don't even I don't even know what I'm
talking about it oh shut the hell up
shut the hell up
sure hello player game anymore I know
how to play I'm only five minutes in
barely if that I don't even think I'm
the five minutes in I'm only five
minutes in and re up to my ears and hate
for this game I've got so much disdain
and dislike and other diss words and got
it spiked like have I been missing pages
have I been so unbelievably distracted
with the amazingly interesting history
of America that I can't possibly I'm far
too energetic for this crap I am far too
hopped up on 10,000 gallons of caffeine
I literally like I don't drink coffee a
lot and drank like two giant tall things
from Starbucks I don't even get coffee
much from there but it was like this
espresso thing was big no huh I'll
follow that cuz probably legitimate no
no I don't know if I could just find
something I would be more than happy to
go about my way but as it stands I've
got nothing oh good I swear on this one
playthrough where I stated very clear I
was gonna play till I finally beat it I
run into all the dead ends I've never
ran into this many dead ends in the
entirety of me playing and I've only
been playing for like five minutes
silence you go screw yourself all you
strange noises okay maybe I'm sorry I
found me some glue sticks whoa
baby is gonna be good
I forgot about that I forgot that that
happened that almost always gets me but
not this time because I'm too hopped up
on freedom in America I love my country
too much to be distracted by these
douches over here so now I just need to
find everything else that ID'd maybe
dead ends are good and I'll be able to
go about my way and if I find a dead end
the naree the correct way will be more
properly established okay let's get it
creepier everyone know your don't fool
with me don't fool with me here don't
fall in the air oh by the bloody beard
of Ben Franklin you didn't have a beard
but I don't even care anymore if you
give me just a dig dog damn door I will
love you forever I will forgive you for
everything that you've done to me oh
please oh now I gotta be careful now I
gotta be careful because I'm a season
when I'm gonna be so dead no no I'll
show you back we knew me you follow me
it's good am i okay I can't possibly be
anywhere we go
I might IV legging with hot food oh my
goodness globby gracious I'm on active
labor just game I cannot believe it I
can't believe it I have never even
gotten I've never gotten the keys it's
early I've never gotten anything that's
early oh my god is gonna get let me read
it oh my god Italy gonna be shut up
no not this time please no no no no no
no no no dodo no no no no no no no
you're gonna not be addictions you still
behind me I don't know how long he
follows but I know there's another guy
here if they cornered me in sandwich me
I'll better be so please let me meet it
this is once just once
Oh but the wouldn't be wouldn't a the
Washington okay which way do I go
see behind me okay oh my Thomas is
Jefferson's um proclivity to have sex
with his slaves oh by the way Americans
we loved our slaves back then
apparently I was a good part of our
history did I not talk about that yeah
that happened a lot okay like that way
ha these clothes sticks they don't do
nothing I know I've said that before in
previous playthroughs but absolutely now
I'm definitely getting the feeling that
they suck giant ass balls oh come on
please please please please please give
me a door a gate the end please please I
am begging you so much I'm spitting
everything I just ate I just want to end
the dormant it's never-ending
it's endless I know you don't
not this time I'm ready for you I'm
gonna beat you and then you got a guard
on your way I don't wanna kill you
you're not gonna kill me and then I'm
gonna get out of here I'll tell my
friends to bring their guns down here
because Americans are given guns at
birth
we gave her we're giving guns before
we're even able to walk
we're bottle-fed mashed hamburgers and
french fries and wash it all down with
milkshakes and then we get our little
chairs that drive us around how did I
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
Halla where did he come from why why did
I buy the steam maintenance room twice
Oh gonna get more American history now
that I'm not going to more American
history
Noel is before the British Invasion of
1779 whereby we declared our
independence from the tea sipping
sissies from across the pond
oh good good for me I found this that's
good right
this good is real good I've our
glowsticks
boom [ __ ] alright okay so anyway the
British didn't like us very much because
we weren't drinking their tea cuz we
Americans like coffee we dip her
hamburger and donuts in the coffee every
morning and then we drink that and then
we pray to the American flag which has a
big middle finger on it by the way I
don't know if any of you actually looked
it up it's just a big middle finger and
everyone else in the world and how much
better we apparently are than them and
then we'd go about our day just waving
our flag down the street parading every
morning singing to the high heavens how
great a ulysses s grant without know so
we're gonna no no I just want to win I
can't talk about American history
I can't uh you get out there you get
higher that's right
keep on steppin
oh come on how long is this tunnel there
we go good stop where am I okay never
mind
sorry sorry sorry sorry let's go this
way let the other way accidentally now
this time don't come up behind me and
stab my neck because I do not much
appreciate that keep on swimming keep on
swimming keep on swimming keep on
swimming he does with a renege he that
helps me alone yeah there was that noise
yeah yeah oh that always I'll go this
way then don't you be still following me
I love my job raging I got the British
people over there who are a delightful
bunch decided that they wanted to kick
our ass so they swam over like they all
just got in the water and start swimming
over here and then they just
individually punched every one of the
colonists in the face and we're like oh
that really hurt hey wait a minute we
remembered our holy doctrine of guns ah
don't ever look back don't follow the
pipes don't run [ __ ] now piece of ass
okay so it told me not to run not to
follow the pipes and never to look back
so that's what I'm gonna do good
whatever find you that way
Wow so anyway the colonists got eats
punched in the face and we were really
peeved off about it and we decided that
we were gonna do something about those
naughty British people over there so we
teamed up with some Canadians or
something and they were like hey what's
going on here we don't like tea either
and they're like okay maybe we should
team up and punch them in the face so
then the colonists in the bridge were
just punching each other in the face
over and over and over again and they
were like oh I sure wish we didn't kill
all those Native Americans maybe they
could help us out
oh no wait they're still pissed at us
because we're [ __ ] and we never like
to make any friends so then we go along
our way and we're like ah for about five
years
no I didn't make the press run let's try
to go this whole way without pressing
run god
dingus dammit my fingers
ha ha that brought ruined it all for me
I'm never gonna win now because I ran or
whatever great this is because I ran
isn't it
this is because I ran they let could
read to go slow yourself go go go go
away
so anyway more history we decided to
team up with the Canadians in the French
and we're like those British guys you
are douches right in the lake I know
right and so we eventually start getting
our asses kicked but then we start
kicking their asses and then we go about
our way and we start waving our middle
finger up in the air and we're like ah
you British people suck you only control
the rest of the world but not us so when
we go about our business for about a
hundred years and then we win two world
wars we think and then we get to the
baby-boomers where everyone's having a
bunch of sexy khals all the time no no
no uh just kill me just tell that you
bastard ah ah I turned out the
brightness because I couldn't see
anything now I can so whatever that's
good - shut up steam I've seen you too
many games is don't Dilla hat I'll give
it out about anything I don't give it
ask about America I don't give an ass
about George Washington I don't give it
as without Mount Rushmore and now the
FBI is rushing to my house to take me
off the internet throw me in a room
where I can't even praise the American
flag everybody well never have
hamburgers again shut you know
my rock Martin ah I can't do it guys
I cannot do it it is literally
impossible for me to win I'm never gonna
win oh look right off the bat oh excuse
my snake
excuse my prolific about those Fred use
this game is a dick bag and I'm a dick
bag for playing it I'm a dick bag for
thinking that I can win I'm a dick bag
for thinking that I can have any sort of
success in this game good this sucks ass
and as it will suck for the remainder of
forever you know this game is actually
long since stop scaring me I only play I
literally only play it because you guys
want me to well [ __ ]
why won't you let me win why will you
not let me have just a little bit of
satisfaction in your [ __ ] game why
why why what have I ever done to you
what I ever done to you game developers
of this game why is it coated to know
that I'm playing it and never let me win
why is it always coated for that why is
it always coated it's hard coded into
the game to know if I playing markiplier
is playing he does not deserve to win
because you have summon [ __ ] you better
than a gun
god I write a data Hey better than in it
it better than edit it
why must you hate me just tell me [ __ ]
you
oh I haven't haven't even been able to
find the generator room or the whatever
the hell the other room is in a long
time I just haven't been able to find
him cuz you know what that's my life
there's apparently what I deserve this
is what I get this is what I get this is
what I get for thinking that I can
actually make good videos for the
Internet
that's why I get but playing a good
games good horror games they like it for
saying it's a good or game cuz it's bad
it's very good it's really good I'm
gonna lose my voice cuz it's bad there's
so much spit everywhere there's
literally more spit all over my my
desktop monitor than I've ever spent
before in my life
I'm gonna lose all my body fluids by
spinning them why can't I beat you why
it should be literally impossible that I
haven't beaten you I played you for
hours hours random chance should've been
on my side by now random chance this is
far beyond random I know this is far
beyond random at this point this is
pretty much fate that I'm never gonna be
able to beat you you are intentionally
taking with me I have looked up boxers
it's totally random there is no strategy
there are those buns okay so just random
hello hey Joe I do every one every one
of these corridors every one of them has
a monster
good god for you
shut the
up you [ __ ] ago ho ho ho oh ho ho ho oh
I sure do love these sewers
hey sooner that Cyril arival ll the hill
Oh
halt I can't wait to die again ha friend
linger today
oh don't blow me out now y'all will help
Google Google is monitor I'll Gary now
they don't revoke my plane as you're my
ball down the loop algebra plane level
you don't get there
great now the vision is shaking that's a
good sign of show collapse of fright any
minute now
ha ha ha ha ha haven't seen the friggin
generator in ages whatever I am just I'm
gonna fall over I'm gonna fall over die
of fright that is gonna be the end of it
that is this gonna be the end and I
don't care anymore
your stupid face doesn't even bother me
I I do not get it I do not get it I'm
just pointing the game where my
character is shaking I found the very
end of the note trail and nothing I
found nothing not even the glow sticks
ah shut up you [ __ ] you I don't even
care I don't care I care
I haven't even run once is the first
time I'm running live live live live
laugh and go look I'm back at the
beginning
Hey oh look it is I forgetting
I got the glowsticks even though I'm
about to keel over and die
I found me close Texas is not just alive
over me if you make me if you get me to
find the keys and then you have me keel
over and die inches from the door I will
hate you game for the rest of my life I
will
oh don't you make me do this game don't
play this game of a do not play the game
of a don't game was late to let me out
go baby fell over and died don't do that
to me
don't break my yard I don't break my
yard have the keys do not please don't
break my art game do not break my art
please please please I'm begging of you
I'm begging of you to let me leave you
let me leave no just let me leave the
other here just let me leave just let me
go - let me go - let me go
since let me go she let me go let me go
- let me go let me go please please
please I'll give you anything
I'll give you so much of anything if you
just let me go you let me go home if you
let me go home if you let me go home if
you let me go home if you let me go home
if you let me go home if you let me go
home please please please I'm begging
you with every fiber of my being
please don't let there be a martyr there
I am begging you with everything that I
have to let me go over I'm gonna kill
over and die and he's taking up and
Blake do log
I played a log up if legs you log huh
the fall over
this introduction is going to get ugly
please let me go let it out let it go up
please baby
oh I'm begging you so hard right now I
do not want to die I don't want to come
this far for nothing
please game please please game game
please please game very please please
game game please please game played life
go baby IV i v-i believe a believe live
liquid please please leave me please
I know I don't I don't I just do the
door to give me the door just give me
the door just give me the door
let's give me the door let's give me the
door
is that the door that doesn't door why
couldn't it be the door no second
chugging I fire forever they over they
get your die
I ain't I